[Музика]
деякі є моєю дискримінацією саме якщо
рік має бути досягнуто безземельної групи,
яка в класиці тут молодий чоловік
майже не милий
[Музика]
привіт всім, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звуть Наталія Ласко, давайте
почнемо
[Музика]
і  сьогодні я хотів би привітати мого
експерта з подорожей привіт Ліза привіт
приємно познайомитися Наталія також приємно познайомитись
як справи сьогодні я добре почуваюся
добре дякую, як пройшов твій день, мій
день був гарним і я впевнений  що у нас
буде дуже гарний урок Ого,
готово, давайте,
тому наша тема подорожі, ви
експерт, і давайте почнемо, хлопці, перше
завдання для вас, подивіться на дошку У мене
є закон два слова швидко знайдіть
слова  які не є транспортом, то
скажімо, ми говоримо про транспорт так,
наші студенти шукають слова,
а ви також шукаєте слова, а чи
є слова, що примітка
транспортний засіб ракета ракета це не
засіб транспорту, я думаю  ні ні ні колодязь,
мабуть, в  майбутнє, можливо, є
добре, але ви можете сказати, що це не
засіб транспорту, добре,
о, і пахне верблюдом, верблюдом, верблюдом, подумайте
про Єгипет, люди подорожують Європою,
що сьогодні так, так, вони використовували, щоб верблюд
міг бути транспортним засобом для менестреля.
двигун лісник пожежна
машина пожежна машина чи пам'ятаєте ви
слово пожежна машина ми вживали це слово на
попередньому уроці, коли говорили про
Лондон і подорожуючи Лондоном, скажи пожежна
машина це машина, якою користується
в пожежній частині пожежник так пожежна
машина  так, отже немає машини
немає машини розмова добре трактор
стояв морські підводні човни гарне лайно про
цей декер подвійний двоповерховий
що це таке я не знаю двоповерховий
це червоний бос так, де ми можемо
побачити червоні смуги, ти пам'ятаєш  в
Лондоні в Лондоні Браво добре глибоко Наталія
корабель
так що за корабель це білий білий
добре це дешево це форма дозвольте мені
намалювати вашу форму добре,
але купив човен о так, так це
човен добре, це корабель, що таке
Титанік, корабель чи човен, напевно,
і у нас є ще одне слово,
подивіться на цю
гондолу гондола гондола гондола,
але у Венеції Венеція так, так, це його
транспорт так, ми використовуємо його так  фігурна дошка
і гондола ще менші,
вони менші і не дуже товсті, дуже
тонкі,
добре, тому давайте сьогодні розглянемо нові слова
для наших студентів, добре, тому подивіться
на дошку і знайдіть слова,
так що Ready Steady Go для студентів
спочатку один два три чотири  п'ять шість сім
вісім
що це і скажімо,
ти допоможеш мені номер один що це
це потяг хороший номер два машина браво
тролейбус це він тролейбус я
не бачу залізницю це не його автобус
просто  тільки для нас так, або ми також можемо
це назвати. Ви пам’ятаєте слово, яке
починається на C Я впевнений, що ви знаєте
Coach Coach так, тому боси зазвичай
подорожують містом, але коли ви переїжджаєте
з одного міста в інше, зазвичай
використовують  тренер Тренер тренер добре добре номер
чотири  номер чотири це план літака так
п'ять овець добре шостий купив
портові рейси і мотоцикл велосипед або
мотоцикл мотоцикл мотоцикл і
вісім його о, ви використовуєте це слово, ви сказали
мотоцикл на цьому велосипеді велосипед так велосипед
добре зроблено зараз нові слова для вас
сьогодні  ми не використовували їх раніше, тож давайте розглянемо
перше слово, яке ви
згадали в цьому уроці, чи можете ви допомогти мені
гондола так
повторюйте за мною гондола гондола і
будь ласка гондола гондола гондола
гондола добре, так, наприклад, у реченні я
люблю використовувати гондоли я  люблю користуватися
гондолами добре зроблено я ніколи не користувався
гондолою я ніколи не користувався гондолою добре
зроблено, так що подивіться на слово подвійне
O's go on the land only good
давайте подивимося на це, чи був цей підводний
колодязь там водна дошка, пам'ятайте
картинку  було на початку
уроку було слово є
підводний човен так морський піхотинець тому повторюйте за
мною підводний човен скажімо
підводний човен молодець підводний човен
подивіться на wo  rd submarine submarine
, ви коли-небудь користувалися підводним човном, ммм, не
таким, а схожим. Подібним
, але меншим, набагато меншим,
добре, тому підводний човен зазвичай йде
під воду, і ви можете побачити, наприклад,
як я використовував підводний човен, коли я
відпочивав у Туреччині
тож ми пірнули у воду й
спостерігали, як риба довкола ви можете використовувати
підводний човен для цього давайте рухаємося далі і
ваші слова верблюд так, ви використовували
верблюда, дякую, давайте йти далі
і що це за трактор трактор повторюйте
за мною
трактор трактор скажімо  трактор
молодець давайте йти далі у нас сьогодні нове слово
що це за слайсер що ти думаєш, що
це не автобус це справді автобус так
тролейбус
повторюй за мною тролейбус
тролейбус давайте знову тролейбус
ти коли-небудь користувався тролейбусом так
курс нелюдського лижного кролика коли я навчаюсь і
живу на лижах
ти щодня я ходжу тролейбусом до моєї
школи або після школи добре коли
ти їхав додому так це був Cibola
Institute University University Univ  ersity так
школа художників піде до університету так,
і я знаю всі тролейбуси за лічені хвилини, тому
ви використовуєте тролейбус для поїздок на роботу
так добре їздити на роботу це коли вам потрібно
їхати з дому на роботу їздити на роботу їздити на роботу
це як місця призначення так, коли ви
подорожуєте  з дому на роботу я їду на роботу
так, ви користуєтеся тролейбусом,
щоб їхати з дому
до школи чи з дому до
університету чи до інституту я дивлюся на
ці слова що це це не
мотоцикл це  менший він не
такий швидкий, то що це я використовував
щось подібне в Італії Італія так,
це дуже типово для Італії, і
давайте подивимося на слова послухайте мене
це скутер скутер скутер повторіть,
будь ласка, скутер скутер
кажуть, скутер молодець скутер
скутер, тож ти користувався скутером так
добре скутер я сам ніколи не користувався
скутером, а ти
коли-небудь користувався скутером
добре, тож давайте ще раз подивимося на
слова так засіб пересування  і давайте
знову подумаємо, що ми можемо використовувати в Єгипті,
будемо сподіватися, що найгірший верблюд верблюд автомобіль
добре, а як щодо трамваю, чи можна ми використовувати
трамвай в Єгипті барабан барабан Rosamond барабан
що означає трамвай пам'ятати трамвай
Трамп ні трамвай до побачення, ні  ні, ні волоцюги
в Єгипті, ні трамваї в Єгипті, поліцейська машина,
поліцейська машина, звісно, пожежна машина, зв
сно, що щодо цього слова та балансу, який ви має
е збалансувати, о, так, я скор
стаюся тим, що добре, що стосується Англі
чи Лондона, зокрема, що ми мож
мо знайти в  Лондон у Лондоні ми використовуємо
поліцейський автомобіль пожежний двигун двигун
хороший пожежний двигун добре Даллас автомобіль пожежна
машина трамвай над цим двоповерховим
двоповерховим парком звичайно, що щодо
таксі, звичайно, ми використовуємо таксі,
а в Лондоні чи в Англії ми дзвонимо
таксі таксі також можливо
таксі чорне таксі так що воно таке ж чи
інше в Нью-Йорку це чорна
машина чорне жовте жовте так жовте таксі
в Нью-Йорку в Лондоні таксі чорне таксі
добре зроблено
як щодо Італії що таке  іди  ing бути
типовим для Італії скутер гарний
гондола гондола гондола гондола гондола
так
автобус хороший trum mm-hmm
train хороша пожежна машина молодець поліцейський
автомобіль таксі ідеальний
чи вони користуються метро чи вони користуються
метро станцією метро Я думаю, що ні в Італії
I'  я впевнений, що ви думаєте, я пам’ятаю
себе, коли вперше поїхав до Риму, і
вони користуються
кімнатою максимізерів і, можливо, інші міста інше
місто так, все добре, це добре
Рим зловив метро, а в Україні ми
икористовуємо метро в Україні так, звичайно, ми
є в яких містах у великих містах,
таких як Київ Харків Харків, добре, так, у великих
містах є станції метро, добре зр
блено, що характерно для України, що ви
ожете нам сказати, верблюд не
иповий для України.  слова але але
підводний човен, але ні, якщо ми говоримо про
Чорне море Lexy так підводний човен так добре
двоповерховий я думаю, ні, ми будемо
використовувати їх на
верблюдах, ні, але в той же час ви
знаєте, що гондола гондола у нас точно
немає  не до Ласу, так, у нас
їх точно немає. Говорячи про
двоповерхові, ви коли-небудь бачили
двоповерховий в Україні я знаю, що ви можете
сказати так, звичайно,
ми в Києві, у нас є туристичні автобуси
туристичні автобуси так, у нас є  двоповерхові
це не червоний автобус, але знову ж таки це
двоповерховий автобус, який використовується для того,
щоб туристи їздили по Києву та щоб побачити
різні визначні пам'ятки, чи є у вас двомісна
Туреччина у вашому місті добре що щодо
джипа чи популярний в Україні Jeep GPS так  ми
любимо їх, вантажівки - це люди джипів, і
іноді ті, у кого немає фішок,
вони можуть нові конструкції автомобілі автобуси
мотоцикли, що припускає все більш
густонаселене, що щодо велосипедів чи знаєте ви
країну, яка досить часто використовує велосипед
чи знаєте ви це так Нідерланди
вони  використовувати велосипеди так, звичайно,
в Амстердамі так, вони зазвичай багато користуються
в Амстердамі та Нідерландах, тому давайте
перейдемо до домашнього завдання для наших студентів:
написати твіт про транспорт,
яким можна користуватися в Одесі, тому ми мали
текст про Лондон, і я попросив вас
написати короткий твіт про подорожі
Едесою,
тож скажімо, чи можете ви розповісти нам, що
буде досить комфортно
подорожувати дорогою Семом, на вашу думку, який
спосіб подорожувати, на вашу думку, є найкращим?
їжа пішки Я думаю про їжу так
, ви згодні, тому що ви знаєте
, що є багато красивих регіонів
і площ, і малих, які ви могли б
попрацювати  щоб подорожувати по DSA
пішки, давайте рухатися далі, тому зараз настав
час граматики робити як бабуся Я впевнений,
що ти любиш бабусю так
потренуйся, тому сьогодні ми поговоримо
про теперішній досконалий час, скажімо,
це не буде так складно
розслабтеся подивіться на жарт як ми
знаємо, що морква корисна для наших очей
, ви коли-небудь бачили кролика в
окулярах, тож це схоже на жарт
Яма 9 покаже більше quoi Запряжений leo
che guevara курка красива
купа хронічних  кіношит  a cool are a
tank, тож це той, який ми використовуємо в теперішньому
досконалому часі, ми використовуємо це для досвіду,
тому кролик ніколи не
носив окуляри, добре, тому давайте розглянемо
більше прикладів, подивіться на цей
, вміст з'їдено в багатьох
різних  ресторани, тож сім'я
перепробувала багато різних ресторанів так,
це особистий досвід або
зміни, коли у нас є особистий досвід
або зміни, які ми використовуємо, ідеальний
безперервний для цього особистого досвіду
чи ви коли-небудь пробували автомобіль
на верблюді, ви сказали так, що бачили
верблюда  правильно так, або ти можеш запитати мене
Наталія, ти коли-небудь пробував гондолу ні
я не пробував гондолу, це мій
особистий досвід, залишити вчора ввечері.
тут важливо те, що
дія подивіться дія, яка сталася в
невизначений час в недалекому минулому
недалекому минулому
наша
доміна дія важливіша за час  e у
нас немає часу тут, тому ми використовуємо
present perfect your coldness guardian
issued o ні так так, і дія
важливіша за час, давайте перейдемо
до ще одного прикладу, він працює
шеф-кухарем з 1999 року або я працював як
вчитель з 2006 року, тому дія почалася
в минулому і продовжувалась дотепер,
тому ми почали ми все ще робимо це
ми продовжуємо це робити, і ми використовуємо
теперішній, ідеальний для цього ви
телезірка, правда маленька телезірка так, це телевізор
зірка ви почали це в минулому,
і ви все ще робите це правильно, ви
все ще є телезіркою так, тож можете сказати, що
я працював телезіркою з тих пір, як ах, і
ви згадали рік AHA, я
працював телезіркою з 2011 року  11 2011 2011
2011 чи можете ви сказати ще раз, я працюю
телезіркою з 2011 року, молодці, тож
давайте підсумуємо, що ми використовуємо презент, ідеально підходить
для дій, які почалися в минулому і
продовжуються до теперішнього часу, він працював
у ресторанах 5 років, почав
працювати  в ресторані 5 год  років тому,
і він все ще там, наступний для
дій, які відбуваються в невизначений час
у минулому дія важливіша
за час, тому він двічі обідав у своїх
ресторанах, коли ми не знаємо,
час не вказано дія  є
важливішим за той час, коли це сталося
ще раз для особистих змін або
досвіду. Я ніколи раніше не їв піцу
або я ніколи не пробував верблюда,
і слова-тригери для вас,
тому слова, які я використав, були
ідеальними просто
для гріхів ніколи  і т. д. Я хотів би
звернути вашу увагу на слова для і
оскільки, якщо ми подивимося на підйом,
добре, то ви маєте початок
періоду і кінець періодів, тому я
почав і закінчив, ми використовували чотири
протягом трьох днів  три роки протягом п’яти
років, але якщо я почав, і я все ще
роблю це, я не закінчив, ми використовуємо
гріхи як приклад. Я працюю
вчителем з 2006 року, ну, скажімо,
ви сказали, що працюєте телезіркою
відтоді  2011 ти почав  і ви все ще
робите це,
ви все ще продовжуєте, і ми знімаємо сцени
так, але коли ви почали і припинили, ми
використовували чотири протягом трьох днів по п'ять днів
на період 10 років протягом 10 років
так правильно,
давайте людям вивчати формування, перш ніж ми
практикуємо  тож підмет плюс половина плюс має
плюс причастка минулого часу вся робота в
сатефоні ось як ми складаємо речення
давайте подивимося на приклад я
був у парку чи можете ви допомогти мені з
його, що ми можемо використовувати з його важкими
бомбардувальниками я ми  ви вони, що він
був у парку о, він був у
парку або вона була, вона була Браво,
давайте переглянемо, як ми складаємо негативні
речення, щоб дієслово було те саме з'їли
з'їли, але ми не мали або не
Тож якщо я був у парку, скажімо, чи
можете ви допомогти мені з негативом, будь ласка,
я не був у парку, парку, і
якщо я скажу, що він був у парку,
він не був у парку так, Браво, добре
а питальні для запитань ми ставимо
мають головки на початку
речення ти був у парку пізніше
ні я не маю Браво дуже дякую
і слова-тригери знову давайте скажемо
разом урок вже але ніколи ніколи
тільки за відпочинок
дякую дуже дякую зараз давайте попрактикуємося з
завданням для вас давайте зосередимося на  дієслова
є два типи слів regular
irregular давайте почнемо з правильних
дієслів подивіться на дієслова, у нас їх десять,
і я прошу вас написати дієприкметник минулого часу
для правильних дієслів скажімо,
ви також виконуєте завдання з нами добре,
так що ви  напиши слова сам, і
Лес тут, давайте перевіримо десять секунд
[Музика]
тепер давайте перевіримо, так що номер один — грати на
пластині номер два менше подобається сподобалося сподобалось
добре зроблено, а ви перевірте зі мною, чи
є у вас те саме  або інше число три
прибери прив'язано
Браво подивіться, що ми змінили
букву Y на I добре, номер чотири
зупинилися, браво і з подвійним P тут
добре, тому що у нас є приголосний голосний
приголосний обговорювали, що так, Drue Mielke
запросив номер  r шість винайшли добро і
номер сім ходив
Браво наступний ніс або ніс його морква
морква так наступний хотів Браво
запусти його і запусти його і запусти це
крапельно подивись на Вау, тепер все добре, ви
можете отримати вісім очок, добре, ідіть чотири
подвоєні P так  зупинено зараз неправильні
дієслова приготуйся швидко
запиши другий і сатефон і ми робимо
з уроком, тому номер один посилає
неправильний пісок пісок пісок пісок пісок
браво break break broke a break broke
broke broken так пити п'яний пити п'яний п'яний
п'яний п'яний пити п'яний п'яний  п'яний
п'яний так бачиш так, оскільки гріх добре, чи
Ден думав так багато сорту добре Рон
бігав бігав бігав браво принеси широкий широкий
широкий широкий правий
написав написано добре вирізати скороти
вирізати скороти
так давайте зробимо це неправильне дієслово
gymnastic буде легше  щоб
ви запам’ятали так ви робите з нами давайте зробимо
це давайте зробимо це з діями в
звичайному дієслові gymnastic так це
інфінітив les oeufs і повторюйте за мною
руками скажімо з t  він
вручає гімнастичний пісок пісок пісок пісок пісок
пісок пісок, тому що другий і встановлена
ма той самий пісок пісок пісок пісок пісок браво ро
битий зламаний перероблений перерва перерва зл
маний зламаний молодець дивитись вибач пи
и пити п'яний браво ди
ись побачив побачив побачив Sigma C  так бачив
Браво
зроби Ден добре тоді подумай ну що так що тому
що
так само добре біг
біг біг біг біг бігаю тому що це
погляд на мене я кажу біг біг біг біг бігай ти
роби з нами біг біг біг біг Браво
принеси принеси принеси  широкий широкий хороший
правий прокат відступає добре і вирізати
вирізати вирізати
дивовижно дякую дуже добре так що
були неправильні дієслова гімнастика для вас
давайте перейдемо до жарту жінки атакують
щит шкільного навчання тому що знання
тільки школа Брюстер необхідність IB який
був на атаку так Ліза  тому подивіться, у
нас є звичайні дієслова, це
буде прочитано, подивіться червоний і зелений, один
буде неправильним, без проблем, ви
пишіть з нами, тому якщо я скажу звичайні дієслова,
укажіть, що ви пам'ятаєте  ber ви можете
подивитися на ваш папір грати в хорошому
стані який ще стан
я зробив мистецтво я зупинився зупинись
хотів добре і зелений один нерегулярний
з'їли нам потрібен сатфон Preta forma
з'їли сцена сцена мм-хм
взяті добре зроблено що ще
cut cut well done, тому я використовую
маркери, а ви дайте мені речення, якщо
я вкажу на вас червоний маркер, ви
повинні дати мені речення зі звичайним
дієсловом okay наприклад я грав у цю
гру okay я вказую на вас, якщо  Я вказую
вам на зелений маркер, ви даєте мені
речення з неправильним дієсловом, ви кажете
з нами, ви починаєте, а потім давайте скажемо
добре, тому прочитайте один урок я зупинився в
цьому готелі в готелі я зупинився
я зупинився в цьому готелі в готелі у мене
зупинявся в цьому готелі Браво,
зараз цей, який я ніколи не їв, мене впевнені, що
ви сказали, що я ніколи не брав
твої гроші, добре, добре, і останній, я
зупинив цей урок, добре зроблено,
що був твій приклад, запиши їх
добре, тому настав час вікторини
, це  невеликий тест, який ви проводите разом з нами  ви
відповідаєте спочатку, а потім орендодавець
відповідає добре, тому він не бачив
Лондонське око, правильне або невірне
Алесія, він не
бачить London Eye, що з
цим не так, це неправильно, тому що він не
бачив Лондон, він так, він не бачив  бачив
лінію пральні виправити наступну готову
ми ніколи не їли суші правильно так
це правильно так правильно наступне
вони не були, щоб стати потворним, що
з цим не так, це
неправильно вони були вони не мають
раю, у них є  я добре відкривав, так
швидко перегляньте слова, і це
буде домашнє завдання для вас, хлопці,
будь ласка, запишіть речення, які я
бачив, і назвіть країну,
наприклад я бачив автомобіль в Одесі я
бачив скутер  в Італії або
я не бачив транспортних засобів у
країні це буде домашнє завдання
вони чують дзвінок, на жаль,
нам потрібно припинити урок дякую
дуже дякую менше дякую дуже
дякую було чудово
до зустрічі  час до побачення
[Музика]
програма  mas are szostak lost she's Mikasa
shimoneta чоловік - allah - masha'allah
[Сміх]
рок-книга Санта-станція через макарони
дивовижна e do super hot o krishna
informati de trabajo de nova sleep
абсолютна без команди tomato tikka do
лаконічний no Chico Sakawa Orhan  кожен новий
рік з коміксами - з каппа равіка
Нестор Хадж чобіток вона
бажає мітозу позатекстова
[Музика]
ти